- Oh, my gosh.
(audience applauding)
That's a really cute outfit.
- Thank you.
I cannot walk in these heels.
I only wore them because I was like,
we're sitting so I'll be fine.
And then on the walk here, I was like...
- I cheated.
- Oh, yes!
- I always cheat.
If I don't have to wear
stiletto, I go platform.
- Those are the best, because it's not...
- You get the height, but
your feet aren't like,
why are you on stilts?
- Right, it's about the angle.
- It's the angle.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, 'cause like this is a crazy angle.
- Yes, that's what I
almost wore out here today.
and then I was like-
- Don't.
- No girl, I'm almost 40.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, yeah, I don't
have to do that anymore.
- I don't want to do it anymore.
- They don't pay me enough for that.
- I can do it if...
- Do you dance in those?
- No way.
- Oh, okay.
(audience laughs)
'Cause I saw you,
we were at the same radio show
doing something one time
this was like years ago
and I was like, oh my God.
You were dancing in some heels.
- I probably went through a phase
where I was like let me push myself
'cause I wanna like,
I like looking taller and
the whole thing but now-
- You do feel sexy in a stiletto.
- You do totally, and your posture too.
'Cause I have like really bad posture,
so sometimes I'm like...
- Me too.
- I'm either like this on stage-
- Yeah, it's always my butt.
- Or like this-
- Or my gut 'cause I'm
breathing like a singer
and it looks really good.
- Like a human.
- Yeah. Yeah
(both laugh)
Then it's always like
suck it in but I can't.
- Yeah, totally.
- Wait, but I heard you just
got your driver's license.
- I did.
(audience applauds)
- That's amazing!
Were you afraid to get yours?
I was a little afraid to get mine,
'cause I was afraid of other drivers.
- Right, I was afraid of myself,
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
I mean, I think my mom
was so afraid for me.
Like she was just like,
you are too distracted.
You're just too much Pisces energy
to be on the highway.
(audience laughs)
And so I was like, yeah,
you're probably right.
You're probably right.
But then I was like, I
think I spent so much time
like feeling like I was
like really, really young.
And then I think me
getting my driver's license
was part of me being like,
you know, I trust myself.
- I'm a grown woman.
- I'm a grown ass woman.
I can do this.
- Watch this, watch this.
(audience applauds)
Mine was never me.
I was always afraid of other drivers
and like big highways
with like mixed masters.
I was like, bridges, I
don't think I breathed.
- I'm still scared of highways though.
Like I drove here,
and every time I drive on the highway,
I'm like, you know how like on the maps
it's like the option without the highways,
and then I'm always like,
damn, it's like twice as long,
but the whole time I'm on the highway,
my butt is clenched.
I'm like today, is the day I'm gonna die.
(Kelly laughs)
Today is the day
- [Kelly] You did it, you made it.
- Yeah.
- We're proud of you.
So, wait, did you have
bad dreams about driving?
I heard that you had some bad dreams.
- Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What were your dreams?
You just wrecked?
- My dreams were always
that I was in a car,
the car was going really, really fast,
but I didn't know what the PRNDL was,
(audience laughs)
I didn't know what the
buttons were on the car,
so I didn't know how to work a car-
- What did you just say?
(audience laughs)
- The PRNDL?
The PRNDL, you know, from
"Suite Life of Zack and Cody"?
(crowd exclaims and cheers)
- The PRNDL?
- Where Mr. Moseby is like
teaching London Tipton
how to drive-
- You know what?
- And he's like, the PRNDL!
(audience laughs)
- We just discovered our age
difference just now. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
I was like, wait, what
the hell is a PRNDL?
- What were your shows that you watched?
- "Saved By The Bell", ma'am.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, (chuckles) I was young
for "Saved By The Bell",
but yes, no that was...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, mine was "Suite
Life of Zack and Cody",
"That's So Raven", anyway, so-
(audience cheers)
- Okay.
I know "That's So Raven", I know that one.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay. Okay. Okay.
- So anyway, so he calls it the PRNDL,
and then, no, she calls
it the PRNDL, right?
- [Audience] Yeah.
- And then he's like, "Oh, would you like
to listen am or fm?"
(audience laughs)
Like, AM or FM?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- He makes fun of her.
But anyway,
(Kelly laughs)
so I had this recurring nightmare
that I was driving really fast,
I didn't know how to brake,
I didn't know how to do anything,
and so I was like...
- [Kelly] Loss of control.
- There's only one way to stop this.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Learning how to drive.
- You gotta learn how to drive.
- Yeah. Totally.
Loss of control.
That's probably what that means, right?
- I always feel like all of my dreams
mean loss of control-
- Mean something.
(Kelly laughs)
What does it mean when you like
lose your teeth in a dream?
- I think, isn't that
also loss of control?
Like you feel like you
have no control over-
- I guess I always feel
out of control. (laughs)
- I think everything is loss of control.
- Yeah.
(both laughing)
- This is my dream book.
The new album is called "Familia",
so tell us about it and
why you named it that.
- Well, I think that, you know,
at the beginning of this album,
I was having such a hard
time, like mental health wise.
I just had like what felt-
- A lot of us the last
two years, especially.
- Totally.
I think for me it started even (chuckles)
before the last two years.
- Yeah, well, then the
last two years didn't help.
- Yeah, no.
- Yeah.
- It was kind of just like, I
think just crippling anxiety.
That was really hard
for me, and I started...
I feel like because I was in
that place, I isolated a lot
and I felt like I wasn't really...
I don't know, I felt like...
I wrote this line in my album thank yous
but I felt like I almost
needed to be kind of healed
or in a better place
before I let myself be seen
or let myself hang out with people
and be vulnerable and be myself,
and I feel like this album-
- I relate to that.
- Yeah.
- And I feel like this album to me
was me being like, really
trusting people, starting with...
You know, obviously, it's about
like my actual real family
and like the roots of that,
but also I feel like the
kind of family that I made
while making this album
and opening myself up to
friendships and community,
and even with my
collaborators in the studio
like, being vulnerable about
what I was feeling and-
- You're very vulnerable.
I heard you allow them to
read your journal and stuff.
You let them read stuff, right?
- Well, I don't like...
I wouldn't be like, you know,
(audience laughs)
you have access to my diary-
- Oh, God, 'cause I'm like, "Nope".
- Absolutely not.
- Yeah.
- But at the beginning, every day,
I would like write in a journal,
and then I would just
like read it to Scott,
and he would be like,
"Oh that's a cool line.
I feel like we could, you know..."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Write a song based on
this lyric or whatever".
So the whole thing for me was really like,
I need to be real and
vulnerable with the people,
like while I'm in the studio,
'cause sometimes I felt like
even being in the studio,
it felt sometimes performative for me,
like I wanna prove that I'm a good writer,
I wanna prove that I'm good.
And this time for me was all about,
Scott, here's like-
- Where I'm at.
- The worst part of like
where my thoughts go.
- Yeah.
- And I feel like that
made my favorite music
that I've made, and also,
I feel like they really, my collaborators
became my brothers in the studio,
and starting to be open with people,
like with the collaborators
and like in the studio process,
extended its way into my real life
where suddenly I was like, oh,
I could be like really anxious
and still hang out with my friend,
and just tell them about
(chuckles) my anxiety.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Instead of being like,
let me cancel because-
- Well, 'cause they're not
rolling in perfect either.
- No.
- They probably got
their own baggage, yeah.
- And I felt like in my mind,
maybe it's because I was young,
I felt like everybody just
did have it more together
than I did.
- Yeah, I think everyone
goes through that.
We all feel that. Yeah.
- And then you grow up
and you're like, (scoffs)
everybody (beep) up.
- Everyone is screwed.
(all laughing)
- Yeah.
- Like we're all in therapy.
- So wait, so you had huge Latin hits
but then you moved away
from Latin music world,
now you're kind of back.
You said a couple years
ago you're now back.
So, does it feel good,
because those are your roots
and it's kind of...
I feel like something that's
super special about you too.
- Thank you.
- Like 'cause you can do
all these different things
in different genres, but it is
something I get excited about
seeing whenever you
perform, I'm like, "Ooh,
this is gonna be fun."
- Right. Right, right.
- Like, and yeah.
(audience member applauds)
And it's gonna be
beautiful and passionate,
and I feel like that's what
Latin music kind of brings
to the table a lot of
times, is like passion and-
- Yes.
- Vulnerability and all of that.
So, was it exciting to kind
of make this album like that?
- Yeah, I mean, I think
like at the beginning,
I was so almost after Havana, for example,
which Havana came about
in such an organic way.
- Which is great.
- And then after when
that had a lot of success,
I felt like when I would go in
with kind of like American
producers and writers,
they were just like here's
Havana version five,
and here's Havana version six-
- Since you've been gone 2.0,
they'd always try and give me that.
- Right.
- It was super fun.
- Yeah, and it's like, this
is very obvious, first of all.
- Yeah.
- And two, I felt like it
just felt not authentic,
it felt like they were kind of putting me-
- And you're chasing it.
- In this box, and chasing
it and putting me in this box
because it was successful,
and so I was like, you know,
I think subconsciously I was
like, I don't wanna do that.
And then I think this album came around
and in working with Ricky
Reed and Scott Harris,
Ricky introduced me to
like this man named Cheche
and this writer named Edgar Barerra,
and they're like actually like Latin.
- Yeah.
- One is from Argentina
and one is from Mexico.
And so actually-
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yeah.
And so actually being in those sessions
and being able to be like, okay,
what kind of songs should we write today?
And then me pulling up a playlist
of like Alejandro
Fernandez, Alejandro Sanz,
Celia Cruz and like-
(audience applauds)
- It's inspiring!
- Yeah, and for other
people to be like, oh yeah!
And did you ever hear that one?
Like, it just made it and
be able to speak Spanish
in the studio, and-
- It felt authentic.
- It felt authentic,
it didn't feel like somebody
was just kind of like money grab vibe-
- [Kelly] This was a hit, so well, yeah.
- Yeah, totally.
So long, I was like,
this doesn't feel right.
And now, I think it
organically went to a place
where I was like, oh,
this feels right for me,
this feels like I'm getting to speak
my first language in the studio.
I'm getting to be with my people,
I'm getting to like you know-
(audience applauds)
- Feels nice.
- Explore that in a genuine way.
So that made me really
excited about this album too.
- I think you're so transparent
in the best of ways.
So I think that that's good.
- Thanks.
- You have to like stick true
to like where you are in the moment,
but thank you for coming to our show.
(audience applauds)
I'm such a fan.
- Camila Cabello, y'all,
give it up! (clapping)